hello folks welcome to rational science
we have a great day today
i'm going to be talking about orbitals
quantum orbitals
what in the world are orbitals
well i've studied them for so long and i
must apologize
that
i have no idea so you came to the wrong
place if you want to know what an
orbital is
but that's proof
that studying
does not give you
knowledge
[Laughter]
okay let's get started with what's going
on in the world today see if this is the
year of extinction
hopefully not hopefully we can all
continue at least one more year okay we
got a lot of things going on we got a
couple wars uh one in the pacific the
other one in
in east europe
and maybe we'll have a couple more who
knows you know it's going to be a fun
year for wars
okay
and uh the war that i'm talking about is
ukraine specifically uh
there's a lot of saber rattling
and people think we are gonna go to war
the armies are preparing for one
apparently for invasion the other one
for defense
and uh the question is what is this war
about
you know i like that from from a movie
uh or is it the reds
where this guy so
was in russian the soviet union and uh
he was
a newsman and
[Music]
they asked him what is this war about
and they thought he was going to give a
entire speech
warren beatty
he just stands up
and he says
profits
and then sits down
that's it that's all wars about profits
right
okay so here's ukraine here's the map i
showed this uh the other day okay and
what you have is the big bear there
that's russia known as the uffsr the
union of fewer and fewer socialist
republics nothing has changed with
russia all these
uh countries today they used to be part
of
the soviet union uh most of them
and little by little they've uh left the
the circle the influence of the russians
like poland there and the
uh romania and so on and uh then you
have ukraine there you can see it's
completely encircled by the russians
uh the green areas those are essentially
in russian hands
and uh there's a little region there uh
that i mark
myself you know that's that's not really
part of the map i marked it myself uh
that's that green uh line
that goes between uh ukraine and a
country known as moldova
okay
and uh that that region uh you might
start hearing about it in the
near future if there is a war because
those people there have uh formed a
country of their own and it's known as
transnistria okay
and here
is a picture of that it's that region
there
that i pointed out okay it's a very long
strip thin strip
and all these people are really
pro-russian
and they're right in between
ukraine and moldova
and that might become a region that also
uh
you know that they can put troops in
there and
and might enter the picture so you
better look it up transnistria might be
a uh
a participant if there is a war
but uh again the question uh we should
ask is uh what is this war about
okay uh
is this a war about uh because you can
see uh you know ukraine is completely
encircled okay so you know you would
think that well it's about ukraine
obviously
well i can give you a different
perspective i don't think it's got to do
so much with ukraine okay ukraine is
like the excuse
okay
and i think this war is about something
else you know you had the first world
war
and it was everyone against the germans
and you have the second world war and it
was everyone against the germans
and this war is going to have a casualty
not ukraine
germany this is the third world war
and again the victim will be germany
okay germany is gonna is gonna be the
big loser here that's my
feeling that's my impression okay
germany's going to be the big loser no
matter how germany plays its cards it's
it's in trouble okay because it's got a
lot of dealings with the russians and
also with the chinese by the way
and united states wants that stopped
okay and the germans don't like that
don't like the americans imposing on
them telling them what to do with their
business especially you know when it's
so vital to them and i think this war
has to do with more with separating
germany
from uh
from from this world in which they
deal with the east
and putting germany
completely
in the west
you know another star
on the flag essentially germany and
france
so uh in that sense it's different in
the first and second world war but i
think germany and france you know they
have a lot of dealings with the east and
i think uh
the politicians in the west want that
stopped
and so i think
the casualty here will be germany and
just time will tell if if there is a war
there's another possibility in fact
there's a couple possibilities as far as
i can think
um
one of them is that um
maybe
maybe it's already in the works
to try to overthrow the government in
ukraine
that would help some of these
governments save face they wouldn't have
to choose sides because if there's a
change of government
in ukraine and that government not
necessarily has to be pro-russia it
could be a little more uh even-handed
maybe it's uh moderate
and it takes no sides and it just stays
calm there is no war
and so if that happens well maybe
everybody saves space
face
and there is no war
on the other hand you know if uh the
russians don't invade
the americans will say okay no problem
we'll continue putting weapons there and
try to recruit slowly and slowly see if
we can get
the ukrainians to join nato okay so so
they're kind of forcing the issue on the
russians
and if on the other hand you uh russia
invades well they lose germany and
france because those will be
those countries will have a tougher time
remaining neutral
and so i think
the the uh
if there's an uh an invasion of some
kind i think germany and france will
lose those who will be the big losers
and yeah
possibly ukraine loses something but
nobody cares about ukraine ukraine's not
that important economically in the world
first of all
and militarily it would help the
americans if they could put their troops
in ukraine and put it as part of nato
but you know that's like a wish
and let me give you another dream
something that might happen
you know and that is
let's assume there is a war
and because of the war you know the
russians uh
economically
start falling backwards
you know because everybody cuts ties
with them and so they lose a lot of
business out there
so what happens let us assume
that there is a coup d'etat
in moscow let's say they overthrow the
anti-western government
well that would be so bad
you know i mean if you think about it
it'd be nice if the russians were
friends with the americans with the
europeans we were all one big family
right
i mean that's better than
having these enemies there
wouldn't that be nice if we all were uh
friends
and then the only enemy would remain
china
and maybe that would be a matter of time
before china collapses as well
and on the other hand there could be
also a civil war in the united states
and that takes precedence over what
happens in europe
that's to think about
okay there are those many possibilities
i think
okay moving on here uh
paul says you cannot transmit this is in
relation to
the moon whether the moon landings
happened the other day some people had
several people in fact had several
things to say about the moon landings
this is one of them and he said several
things i just pointed at uh picked up uh
his number his fifth point there
uh because i thought it was the most
important of the ones that he made the
one that can be analyzed the more
objective
and so he says you cannot transmit live
television from the lunar surface with
the power output they had available in
lem6 okay you cannot survive in a
.0001 torr vacuum using a spacecraft
developed in 1969
we have nothing even today that could
withstand such a powerful vacuum
a lot of people think this way okay a
lot of people out there believe that
you know we can't withstand the vacuum
of space we don't have spacesuits to
withstand it other people talk about the
radiation you know that just zaps you
and that there is no way a lot of flat
earthers especially you know the
flat earthers
uh and they you know they believe that
humans cannot be
can't go into space because of all these
things uh we can't stand the vacuum we
get zapped uh maybe the um
magnetic field affects us you know
different things
and so
they have this notion that you know we
we can't go into space
okay so first thing i want to show is
the following for this gentleman here
who's visitor
and it's this uh he might want to do a
research on this subject i did quite a
bit of it uh in the past i do have the
um
papers written by uh the people who
made the glenn research center okay and
why they built it the way it is
with the
vacuum
that level that they achieve on a
regular basis and here it is it says the
chamber can reach a vacuum level of what
4 times 10 to the minus 6 torr
not very
uh
not the highest of vacuum
it's called uh high vacuum then you have
ultra high vacuum which is above this
minus seven range minus seven torr range
okay so this is not ultra high vacuum
and
the moon is at 10 to the minus 11
according to three of the probes that
went out there and measure the vacuum
level on the surface of the moon
and the solar wind is a little even
thinner it's a minus 12
torr
so there abouts it's a very high vacuum
ultra high vacuum what they call
and so the question is why would they
build this uh
testing center in ohio
at ten to the minus six
i mean the astronauts are gonna go into
the ten to the minus eleven
and so the the couple papers that were
written when they built this uh facility
uh explain all that they said you don't
need to test an astronaut at minus 11
level
minus 11 torr level you do not need to
do that
already at -6 you will die okay please
understand that first you don't need to
go to minus 11. so and then uh the the
lack of pressure at minus 11 to minus 6
is not that significant when you're
talking about humans especially when
they're you know when they're covered by
their suits it's not like they're going
to be exploding because suddenly you
went from -6 to -11
high vacuum already is is pretty good
vacuum to test a human being you do not
need to take them to ultra high vacuum
but if you go to ultra high vacuum
there's very little difference from a
health
point of view
from minus 6 minus 7 to the minus 11
minus 12 range
okay so all i can do is
show you where uh to look for the
information and there are several papers
written on this okay on this subject
but um talking about that
let me get rid of this
talking about that subject here we have
the chinese
and they recently went out into space
and they're in the middle of space what
do you what vacuum level do you think
these people are experiencing there
assuming you believe that this was not
done in chinese hollywood okay
these guys are working in outer space
okay and uh
or so they claim so china claims
and nobody questioned that the americans
didn't question it the russians in
question nobody's questioning that these
guys were not in outer space they do
have you know ways of detecting whether
this is true or not you know was
with uh telescopes and so on
uh
these guys are working out there in
outer space and the question is you know
what vacuum level do you think these
people are subjected to
and if they're in the middle of a space
you're talking about again minus 10
minus 11 minus 12 range tor right range
and so you know i mean
uh you really got to do a little more
research
on vacuum levels
and people say a lot of this they maybe
read some
something written by a flat earther
maybe and they say oh oh here it is no
no you got to do a little bit of
research if you're really going to hold
an opinion
and you know i work with vacuum quite a
bit all i can tell you is
uh
you know uh
humans
can uh with with the suits on right can
withstand minus six minus seven level
and they did so all the way till the
sixties you know they didn't send these
guys out there without their clothes on
uh even gagarin the guy who went around
the earth and so on all these people
were you know with suits
inside their their
vehicles
so to say that humans cannot withstand
that you know they do test them at this
glenn center they put a guy in there in
this chamber
and they pull it and pull this thing
down to minus sixth level
and you know to say that he can't
withstand it even with the equipment we
have today with the suits we have today
it's ignorance that's all it is you
gotta kill your ignorance go out there
do research and you'll find out that
yeah that's
uh with the suits we've got today we can
withstand uh
the lack of pressure
uh you know up to the minus eight minus
seven minus eleven pre uh level toward
level
okay another common on moon a lot of
moon moonies
pseudo science cultists will believe in
such
nonsense as the moon hoax because they
are stupid gulliver
yeah i mean you know um the question is
did man go to the moon
and a lot of people out there don't
believe it
and so they raised a lot of issues like
you know what about this and what about
that and here here i'll give you
one fellow he said the following
let me remove this file here
this vowel says the following okay
he says i remember seeing the astronauts
jumping around on the moon allegedly
then recall then recall that i was
taught that gravity on the moon was
something like one-sixth of what it was
on the earth uh-huh so i
expected they would be jumping several
feet off the ground easily
that's not what i saw really pretty weak
jumps and you can see it there the guy
jumps but maybe a couple feet off the
ground you know as he jumps around
and falls back down
and so people say ah see this was done
in hollywood
well all i can tell you is the following
for all those people who believe in
these things and these arguments okay
here's here's a list of arguments just
pulled off the top of my head okay i
didn't do great research on it i just
pulled it off the top of my head and
here it is the errors of cosmic
proportions i call them okay
uh no stars in the background some
people say that there were no stars in
the background so this was done in
hollywood or wherever uh the flag waved
you know
uh gravity jumps as i just discussed
okay
shadows cast by the astronauts
and i put a new one i don't know if this
is true but i put that one in there you
know the
astronaut takes off his helmet
okay oh that could have been done on the
moon right
and you know a lot of this uh
these conspiracy theories came out in
1978 with a movie called capricorn one
which i saw i liked the movie not that i
believed it but it's a nice movie
because it shows how these astronauts
are removed from the capsule they're put
into a center and they say look we got
to do it without you guys because
that vehicle is screwed up and uh we're
just going to send the vehicle out into
outer space just in case so nobody gets
hurt right and then bring it back and
you guys are heroes you just have to act
in front of the tv right now that you're
on the moon that you're on this was a
mars expedition that you're on mars
well uh the story goes that when the
vehicle comes back it explodes in space
so it's destroyed and now they have to
kill the astronauts because
because if they appear in in real life
they say oh they were weren't you on
that captain weren't you dead
and so a lot of these um
story a lot of these conspiracies came
over
at least took a lot of force because of
that movie okay there were a couple more
movies after that was the same theme
and yeah the the issue uh
uh that i raise against those arguments
is the following okay and i just want
you to bear with me a second
if hollywood were to make a movie okay
in fact i think it happened where the
romans are fighting i don't know the
greeks or the germans or whoever
and the guy's with his sword and he's
banging away
and
suddenly you see that he's got a rolex
watch
the actor
you know it screws the whole movie
because the guy's waving near his his
sword he's got a rolex watch now how
would people
in the movies look at that a big failure
you know that's of cosmic proportions
and so here's the question for you
uh do you think that the people who made
the movie
of humans going to the moon
do you think they they would have made
so many errors
i mean you would think that their
profession at least they know exactly
you know how physics behaves out there
uh they know a lot of uh
physicists and so on out there gonna say
oh but hold up how about this and how
about that
so if they made a lot and made this
movie in hollywood right with all these
uh
errors
well someone's gotta be fired because
you would think
that um
somehow they would have um cleaned all
this stuff out before showing the movie
to the public right
in other words imagine they allow this
movie
to go to the public with so many errors
no stars in the background the
astronauts not jumping high enough
uh you know then you have uh
what the shadows are not right uh you
know all this all this stuff that they
find out the flag waving
would have made so many errors
the more errors people find
the less
believable is their argument
because what they're saying is that all
these guys in houston nasa who made uh
this fake movie
you know to convince the public of
something
uh that they missed all these errors
they're so stupid that the director of
the movie just made so many errors no
one caught it and they just passed it on
to the public to millions of people
so think about that i mean if you find
one error in some minut areas well they
could have missed this
the director didn't see that there was
this pebble on the ground that wasn't
supposed to be there or something like
that
but to say no stars the flag wave the
shadows are wrong and blah blah blah
jumping is wrong if there's so many
errors
you have a problem
not not the movie
there's something you don't understand
about physics okay that that's my five
cents worth there okay
okay another fellow i think along the
same line says uh
does the moon revolve around its uh own
axis tesla did not think so and there's
nick good ol nick
and uh yeah
essentially the moon doesn't revolve it
doesn't spin
what it does is always shows the same
face towards the earth
and don't be fooled by the
bright light on the moon that's rolling
around look at the arrow
the arrow tells you that the same face
is being pointed towards the earth at
all times okay the light that you see
there the
light shadow uh that's from the sun
okay so the moon always shows the same
face to the earth because it does not
spin
it's what is known as a synchronous
satellite okay
so uh yeah tesla was right on that issue
one of the few things he was right about
tesla was not a scientist by the way he
was an inventor he was a technologist he
he was a lab boy that's all he was
and he invented some stuff patented some
stuff got into a big war with uh edison
one guy with westinghouse the other guy
with edison
was going to be general electric
and
apparently tesla lost
a couple of his
arguments a couple of his patents
you know marconi uh upbeat him uh
won a case against them then the u.s
government brought a case against
marconi and one against marconi saying
that his patent was
not valid they said that many years
later after he had already won the nobel
prize in and beat the hell out of tesla
and so on so yeah it's a great world
you got to look at that whole story it's
really funny how all that history turned
out
okay here's uh
another issue phil says black-eyed
babies stronger than
other babies mean maybe new mutations a
new human species very strange things
happen
some people believe that we're going to
continue evolving and who knows into
what uh maybe into robots uh
[Music]
you know um
what what can we expect in the future
or are we it are we as perfect as we
will ever get
and that's my five cents worth on that
i'm saying we're already there
uh we're as perfect as we'll ever be
uh we have all the intelligence the
maximum intelligence that mother nature
god the devil and all of them put
together father universe that they can
give us
there is no higher intelligence in the
universe
in heaven or in hell
than the human mind
this is it but guys i i know you believe
in super intelligence something out
there no no this is it we're as
intelligent as there is anything in the
universe we have the ability the reason
to understand
whatever god the devil mother nature of
other universe wishes to teach us
okay so
uh if one of these fellows you know
supernatural beings comes over here and
teaches us something
we have the ability to understand it
and that's as intelligent as it gets
anywhere in the universe so if you're
looking for more intelligence because
you feel that you've been gypped
uh you got it wrong
this is it
it doesn't get any better than us okay
that's the maximum the universe can give
you
so all those people who think about
super intelligence and that there's some
being out there that have super
intelligence and they can come here and
show us all their technology which is uh
you know mind-blowing and so on
too much hollywood movies take a break
that's what i say to you okay
okay here we have a fellow talking about
climate change says the reality of
climate change is the ozone layer
actually uh trashed
uh the sun is definitely much hotter on
your skin
winters are warmer i don't know it
probably doesn't has never come to
germany because it's it's been cold here
this whole year we haven't seen the sun
it's just been ridiculously cloudy uh
is methane rapidly releasing from
siberia another ocean floor uh
permian i guess you know he's uh looking
at that
is this a rapid warming
is this a rapid warming before grand
solar minimum or some other mechanism
puts us into an ice age
and yeah
i don't think we're going to see an ice
age like you know maybe
14 12 14 000 years ago
um those things take time
a lot of time and a lot of it has to do
with again pollution in the air a lot of
it contributed by humans obviously
we're eight billion people throwing
garbage up there in the air right among
them our own respiration
every second of the day so
yeah climate does change and we do have
some effect on the climate in fact a
single human being already should be
changing the climate
his tiny grain of
sand but he's contributing to the beach
just by breathing and exhaling he's
already changing the climate
uh you may say well that doesn't change
the climate much yes a drop of water in
the ocean correct but he's already
changing the climate
and so does the climate change every
second of the day every day every minute
every second in the life on earth
uh in the history of earth has
like the the climate has changed
so the issue is uh should we be worried
about it and my answer to you is why
should you worry about it if it's a very
very slow process
by the time it happens you won't be
around for sure and i don't mean
necessarily because there's going to be
an extinction which i think will happen
but even if you last uh you know if
you're 20 years old i don't think it's
going to happen next 60 years you're
going to be 80 years old maybe 90 maybe
100 and
whatever climate change there is
it's not going to kill you
for sure so i don't think you have to
worry about climate at all a lot of this
climate change has to do with
jobs with creating jobs and not so much
with the danger to humanity okay
uh again my take on that so if so is
that mechanism natural or have we done
all this before
uh yeah again i think um it's a natural
mechanism in the sense that you know
every person contributes to climate
change just by breathing
in that sense
uh
there's not much we can do about it
you know we contribute to climate change
simply by breathing
okay another fellow says uh they know
talking about the rich and
filthy rich and uh
affluent
they know they're not going to space
probably unless they already have
and just don't tell us cattle that man
has been traveling the star for some
time
he thinks uh
a possibility that the rich and powerful
have already traveled through space but
they're not going to tell us you know
what i mean because maybe we all want to
get on the spaceship and leave the earth
so that just leaves running off to their
underground cities and hoping to wait it
out you know and they have the gopher
holes people believe the rich and
powerful have all these cities
underground and if we could just find
them we could join them there you know
maybe
again too many movies
that's the problem with all these people
they probably knew you didn't want to be
around for whatever went down and just
decided to go to go do something else
with the time we have left
so um
a lot of people believe this that the
reason powerful the illuminati the new
world order folk and
the skull and bones and all these
organizations secret organizations of
rich people and what they're doing is uh
creating all these secret cities
underground they're gonna go down there
when uh you know the [ __ ] hits the fan
uh
all i can do is tell you my i give my
five cents worth
it it doesn't matter if uh people like
trump or
or you know bill gates
uh go underground to their private city
are they going to go down there alone
how did they build that city
did they build that city with
by themselves with a little shovel or
did they hire a company to do the
city underground
and of course you would say that they
probably hired someone a lot of people
out there to work underground because
you got to dig you got to build the
installations down there at the in you
know in the bottom floor
and then you gotta live there and the
question is uh bill gates gonna live
there alone
uh maybe he takes
lots of people down there with him like
you know uh to help out when things you
know when everybody on the surface is
dead
so they can now you know come out of
there
well the question is what control does
bill gates have over those people at
that point because at that point money
is no more
what control does he have can he order
them to do something say or i won't pay
you your salary
no kid
yeah i mean
once you you're down there
you can't you can't have people
who are not part of your
loved ones maybe you know that's a good
way of putting it i mean if you're
paying them if they're salary people who
work for you for money
that deals off once money is no more so
the rich people have no control
over the people they hired
down there to help them or to be
servants or to whatever
and that's not counting the people they
hired to make the whole
who know where the hole is
and will say oh i want to go down in
that hole because i know what that hole
was for
and besides the fact that these people
would spread the word right now
and tell other people oh by the way you
know bill gates built a hole there in
the middle of south dakota
so so this notion that all these cities
are underground
are people who watch too many hollywood
movies okay
going down under
right
is not going to
[Music]
help you survive if you if you're going
to need people to help you
people you don't know people who you are
paying salaries to that's the first
issue then the second one is to build
that hole down there
someone else knows and that person is
going to tell some other people
and so on and so forth so we should all
know where all these holes are right now
okay
now could there be one whole some person
out there who did it yeah it could have
been and again that person has to watch
out because this is not a question of
hiding it's a question of securing your
future how do you secure your future
uh
other than with money
and if money is no more
what future has you secured for yourself
okay so keep all this in mind you got to
think this over
at least uh that's my line of thinking
my train of thought okay
now the foul says isn't technology just
a synonym of tools in a way yeah
that's what
uh
[Music]
technology is manufacturing is tool
right
innovations are not technology yeah
correct and that's why i
define innovation and uh invention i
separate these two terms and i'm saying
invention has to do with objects whereas
innovation has to do with concepts
that's essentially the difference
invention belongs to physics
okay invention is not how you do
something more efficiently invention is
a gadget
that does something
and that has to do with physics okay so
i separate those two and that's why we
need to separate these two words because
only
invention belongs to physics innovation
doesn't okay
and it says technological progress will
slow down soon
yeah in fact i i'm saying that there's
been no
invention no real invention since the
computer
uh anything else is just putting things
together like you know the smartphone
what is that it's uh an all-in-one
it's all these inventions that already
were on on the books
you have a radio there you have a
television set there you have a
telephone there you you have a computer
there you have all in one and on top of
that it's portable
that's what we always wanted there is
and that's not an invention it's just a
you know putting several inventions
together
so we have no real invention today the
invention the age of invention is over
okay
whatever invention you see out there
maybe to make money
uh
you know it's uh cosmetic
it's it's minor it's not it's not a real
invention like the telephone was an
invention because it put people to work
the car was an invention the airplane
was an invention it put tons of people
to work because industries were built
upon those inventions people wanted to
have those things
you know they wanted the airplanes they
wanted refrigerators they wanted tv sets
and once we invented all that we're done
we don't have any
mind-blowing inventions today nothing
especially what i'm referring to is that
puts people to work
manufacturing is dead never will it rise
again i don't care what you invent today
you might make a buck you know invent
what a pet rock and you start selling
say oh i invented the pet rock great you
make some money
you say well that's an invention yeah i
guess you could call it an invention
you know i'm talking about stuff that
you can use that people want by the
billions out there because suddenly you
know everybody needs one
we have all the things we always wanted
we all now you want a better computer
yeah they'll invent what you want a
better phone yeah you can have it but a
phone is a phone a phone and a tv is a
tv is a tv and a computer is a computer
a computer
nothing's gonna change that
you can't invent the chip again because
the chips already been invented and so
on down the line so this notion that oh
we're once we reach like the people like
kurzweil say uh
the singularity there's gonna be just
exponential growth of technology
what technology what invention what are
you gonna do what is it that you need
what is it that you want
in your life
that's already that's not already out
there
i mean you know maybe a machine that
takes you to the fourth dimension
that would be an invention
if you can make it through the fourth
dimension but a vehicle is a vehicle a
vehicle i mean what do we have flying
cars is that an invention
uh you know i mean people dream a lot
and they watch too many movies and they
don't have their feet planted on the
ground manufacturing is dead it'll never
rise again
it's uh
advanced nations anywhere from 15 to 20
percent of their gdp and labor force is
manufacturing and dying slowly
being smaller and smaller and smaller of
gdp and of labor
so even if you invent i don't know
something unimaginable because people
cannot even tell me what they would
invent because if you can tell me if you
can dream
i'm not asking you to build it i'm
asking you to dream about an invention
that doesn't exist that that people
would buy by the billions
if you can conceptualize it
you're a genius
okay if you can conceptualize something
that everybody wants that we need
we already have all that
all the stuff that we needed we already
had
to make our lives comfortable okay we
have the couch we have the bed we have
the table we have the
uh
what is it the stove we have the
refrigerator for our beer very important
in my place my my life
we have everything we need
what else do you need we
the kings of old the pharaohs they they
didn't have all this stuff they didn't
have toilets they didn't have uh you
know bathtubs or showers we've got
everything we need we don't need
anything else
that's why we're not inventing anything
because the guy who invents something
today really has to go out of his way to
really come up with an invention that's
how difficult it is to invent something
new look at the games gaming industry
what else is there it's game after game
after game is it's just the same game as
existed before just some minor changes
and there it goes
so no there are no new inventions and
there never will be inventions that put
people to work okay
that's that's the
uh criteria okay
okay uh phil says uh
is it rational to debate history
rational to debate history for example
whether or not
mao killed people or whether or not we
went to the moon
it seems irrational because it is all
based on
uh uh
saw and heard in other words past tense
right
and all i can say is you know uh
science deals with two aspects one is
physics the other one is philosophy
and
i don't do philosophy here but that is
the other branch of science
and what does that include well
philosophy includes history
what is it well you're you're trying to
figure out why someone did something in
the past
and again like i said last time uh i
haven't seen napoleon
you know i haven't shaken hands with him
and
so does that mean napoleon never
was around he never existed
i'm sure that in his day he he was there
and how do i know that well i know that
because other people pass that
information down to me like you know
they used to pass all these
stories from father to son
in the tribes and the old plans
and
a lot of them filled with mythology
again but the deal is that's how they
passed it on from generation to
generation and we invented uh something
known as writing
and through writing we do it today and
so if you want to know what happened in
the past well you don't have to hear it
from word of mouth which we do as well
in school but you can read a book and it
tells you what happened in the past
and i don't mean that you have to
believe you know whether washington you
know chopped a cherry tree or or
something like that
maybe you don't want to believe that but
to deny that washington existed
you know 200 years ago
that's
that's a different step that you're
taking there okay
so
certain things you don't want to believe
but certain other you know you're going
to deny that napoleon never
happened that julius caesar never
happened so what are all these people
writing about in the past
you know they pass this information
continuously from one generation to the
next we got it today you're gonna say
that julius caesar never happened
and so this is this is where i see the
problem with the reasoning that these
people have
uh they are throwing the baby with the
wash water in this case right they're
saying look uh i haven't been there i
haven't touched it i haven't seen it so
uh it never happened
the nuclear weapons were never dropped
on japan jfk never was assassinated
because he didn't exist to begin with
uh and so on and so forth
no you at some point you got to draw the
line and say you know some things you
gotta accept because that is our history
and i'll give you a a a specific point a
a good analogy here
you know we find uh for the question
this person asks
uh we go into the rock to the layer of
rock
and we drill in there and we find a bone
turns out it's a dinosaur bone
big bone suddenly you know they say well
this animal doesn't exist today with
that has this head
and you say well maybe it's a fluke
maybe it's an elephant who had arthritis
okay now you find another one similar to
that and another one another when you
find several of them and you can't find
these animals around
so their
history right
well you gotta explain that especially
the layer of rock in which they were
found you say well hold it how much dirt
fell on top of these guys well 60
million were
years worth of dirt
and so this guy was buried way beneath
that is history history of life on earth
and so now you see this this uh this
bone in in the layer of rock you pull it
out and now you can explain it
and so in that sense yeah you gotta
history does play uh uh
you know some kind of uh
role
at least in science in that sense and
for sure in the same way you can
translate that into history and say look
if i find a bone
like the other day they found the uh
remains of um richard iii the king
richard iii who fought at bosworth
and uh you know they find a bone and
they say oh we found the bone we they
checked it out with dna and they said
they confirmed that's him likewise they
found the uh the uh
what is it the
family the uh royal family of russia you
know the tsar
uh nicholas and his family
and so they get these bones you know
these people are not alone around but
those bones belong to someone it
coincides with the history that we read
we have to say these people we're there
you can't say oh i don't believe
in uh
in the the romanovs uh were ever there
because i i wasn't there i didn't shake
hands with them
you know so
yeah
history does is part of science the
behavioral part the why they did
something why they behave this way why
did they go to this place why did they
not go to another place that part is is
the science part okay and so yeah you
can't just
uh deny all of it and say no i'm not
gonna accept uh any of that okay
so um
uh just keep all that in mind okay
anyways uh let's move on to physics
today
uh we're gonna go with the um
with this issue of um
uh the
orbital okay what in the world is an
orbital
we hear about it we see it
uh drawn it's we have an illustration we
have an image
of the orbital okay and it turns out
that uh
it doesn't coincide
with
with what they're explaining
and they cannot justify that orbital
and so it all comes
partly because a question that a person
asked the other day but i already had
this on my things to do list this
question i just told them to take a rain
check on it okay and so just uh keep
that in mind
he says could you explain how the
different atomic substances the elements
are accounted for in the rope hypothesis
model
very important question very good
question
and there you see the atomic orbitals
okay
and you can see uh they're all balloons
and you wonder what all those balloons
are
okay
we're gonna find out that those are
regions
in which you can find the electron beads
so these are regions these are balloons
but you don't see them in the standard
model we don't see this these balloons
in there and say well this material is
made out of i don't know whatever
uh and they call it this or that no
these are supposedly regions that's
where they're supposed to be regions
where you can find the electron bead
okay so that's the overall notion of
this thing called an orbital okay
and another fellow along the same lines
he asked the question he says make a
video presentation about the pictures
that we have of adams aha
and so
what is he referring to well he's saying
a lot of people argue against your views
and rational physics because they have
pictures of atoms
so they have pictures of atoms and so
they say bill you're wrong if we have a
picture here are you gonna deny the
picture
okay
so that proves to them that the atomic
theory is true
so first we attack those two words proof
and truth
okay those belong to religion that means
that you are convinced of something what
is true to you is a lie to your neighbor
okay so
you know to you maybe god is truth and
to your neighbor he's an atheist he
doesn't believe in god so for him god is
not true and so to you it's been proven
to him it's not
okay so truth and proof are part of
religion they have nothing to do with
science okay in science we have to be
objective
and it's got to be an objective theory
an explanation of something in physics
we explain mechanisms
okay so um
here is uh
something that will clarify to this
fellow
about his question he said he wants to
see an atom
and this came out on june 28 2021 not
even a year ago okay and if you look at
the title says see the highest
resolution atomic image ever captured
this is the highest this is the state of
the art here fellas okay
and it was again less than a year ago
and it's this uh compound okay some
metal there and it's got bris press
scandium and oxygen and these are
different elements and there you have
the atomic structure in the case of
prazodinium
it's got 59 protons and 82 neutrons in
the center in the nucleus there scandium
has 21 and 24
and oxygen 8 and 8.
and there you can see the structure in
the upper right of what you're staring
at on the bottom right
okay and i've identified there you know
the uh place odenium uh the scandium and
the oxygen you cannot even see it
because it's so small
now
this is the best image the highest
resolution atomic image
okay that's the first thing you have to
note here
and the question there can you see the
orbiting beads
can you see a single electron orbiting
the atom
and the answer is obviously no you can't
see it
you can barely see the uh biggest of
these atoms
which i've
showed there i've identified there you
can barely see that from like a
bird's-eye perspective
and certainly you can't see not only the
little beads going around but certainly
you cannot even see the nucleus which
has again in the case of preciodium uh
59 and 82. okay so you got 141
uh
nucleons in there okay and so you got
141 of them you can't see one
yeah because again this is uh
seen from a bird's eye perspective
okay if this is the highest resolution
that we could ever have
then clearly we've never seen a hydrogen
atom which is much smaller we haven't
seen an electron we've never seen a
proton we've never seen a neutron we've
never seen any subatomic particle
because we cannot see even atomic
particles okay
this is the best we've got right there
you see it there okay now uh i want to
show you something because how did they
determine that picture there okay did
they take a snapshot they say oh here's
a snapshot now let me show you how they
determine this okay and here it is it's
known as tycography okay and this is the
process
of how they detect these things how they
take pictures images it's not even a
picture it's an image right
a computational method of microscopic
imaging okay that's what uh tychography
is
it generates images by processing many
coherent interference patterns that have
been scattered from an object of
interest
so they play around with certain
lighting certain
images and they
from this composite they make you know
one image and that's what you're seeing
there
and what we just saw is something from a
birdseye perspective
okay so they construct this little by
little like piece by piece and the best
they can do is what you see there at the
bottom there you know again a bird's-eye
perspective of this film
maybe you can see
individual atoms from uh from far away
that's it that's the best you got there
this is the highest resolution we ever
could attain okay
and so it's interesting because
uh what was in
uh you had a group of swedes
university in sweden
and they claimed to have filmed an
electron
and it was put throughout the world in
almost every uh scientific news or uh
outlet right here it is that's what it
looks like here's one uh site that put
it out name uh photonics
okay and what they
say here is that um again that they film
this electron bead
and it said that an electron's rapid
motion has been filmed for the first
time with ato seconds
laser pulses showing how an electron
rides a light wave after being separated
from an atom
so they're claiming that this is a
single electron that they were able to
film
and uh part of the problem here is that
you can see that you see some little
lines there
so so it's like this electron is made
out of parts when it's
uh known even today defined today as
being a particle a point particle that
can't be seen that doesn't take up any
space and which is not made of even
smaller parts
and here you see all those issues
violated in one picture not only is the
electron identified it shows you what it
looks like it's uh some kind of ball
some kind of circle okay
and it's made out of parts
so we got a problem because on the one
hand they tell you one thing that no one
can see an electron is so small they
don't even know if it has any size
whatsoever they call it a point particle
they say it's got zero
uh
size
some people say well it says we can't
see it but
there's two versions of that
and here they say something totally
different they even filmed it i wonder
when these people are going to gain
their nobel prize you know for having
filmed the electron but it says there
until now it has been impossible to
photograph electrons since their
extremely high velocities result in
blurry pictures the movie of electron
motion was created by scientists etc
their method involved using a
stroboscope and a laser that generates
the extremely short life pulses needed
to capture the movement of an electron
once it is pulled away from an atom okay
so uh
you figure out
uh these people are contradicting
themselves constantly
on the one hand they say look the best
image we could ever get is this uh
compound because it's not even an atom
they had all these atoms within that
compound it's a bird's eye perspective
it's got 141 nucleons in one case right
the other one had but 44 i think
and you cannot see a single one of those
nucleons
what you see is
a bird's eye perspective of the whole
atom which does not look like beads
going around it looks like
ball
and it turns out that each one of the
nucleons is
at least 1800 times bigger than the
electron which these people claim to
have filmed
you figure out okay i think these people
are just getting their names in lights
it's uh
known as a scientific lie
it's a fib
okay so uh what's the issue today with
this orbital thing well again we haven't
seen any of these atoms
but as you saw just a minute ago the
uh
orbital
of that uh of those atoms
we sum from far away and they all look
like balls
they all look roundish they all look
like balls in fact every time you see an
atom being like they say we took
pictures of an atom every time you see
those atoms they all look like balls
round balls all of them
okay and so here uh i showed the other
day you have the uh proton and the
neutron okay one has
two up quarks and one down quark the
other one has two down quarks and one up
quark those are those uh red and blue
things inside that that sphere okay now
the question i asked the other day was
look uh
okay
here you have these two uh entities
right these two particles
and why did they draw them with that
sphere around it why didn't they draw it
for example like this
wasn't supposed to be like this because
what is that sphere you know are they
putting that in by hand
you know what what is the sphere i mean
let's take all that stuff out let's just
leave the sphere now there we have the
sphere
what is that sphere that encapsulates
the uh proton and the neutron
and again you won't find it anywhere i
identified anywhere in quantum dome
you'll never find what this is so they
put it in by hand they just make believe
why because they want to show that the
quarks do not leave the uh proton or the
neutron they don't just spontaneously
fly away and so if you know if they're
encapsulated
in this sphere
then people understand just by looking
say well i see why the quarks don't fly
away not only are they bound together by
these gluon springs but on top of that
they have all this sphere
within which they're trapped they're in
prison
okay they can't leave this spherical
prison
but they never identified that spherical
prison that's the issue what material
what is that just name it give me a name
for it
and they call the whole thing the proton
or the neutron
well we have a very similar situation
with the orbital in fact it's almost
identical one is an analogy for the
other okay here you see it okay
here we have uh
these balloons
and all these balloons that you'll see
out there
these are the orbitals
and you say okay what am i staring at
what are these balloons in fact uh in uh
regular chemistry class and physics
class in college they simulate them with
balloons with actual balloons they say
look imagine this balloon like this
balloon like that and they play around
with the balloons the teachers the the
instructors they they play around with
the balloons to show you how the atom is
constructed they never use
you know the little particles flying
around they can't do that you know
because they can't simulate like the
hydrogen atom with a proton in the
center and the little uh electron beam
flying around unless they somehow tie
that electron to the proton they could
do it if they had a little string or
something but without that string they
can't simulate the electron going around
the proton
and but here
what you're seeing all these balloons uh
they're supposedly the uh orbitals
or energy levels
and yeah they do simulate them with
balloons and that's exactly how you see
them there okay so what are orbitals
someone asks you they're balloons okay
that's what they are okay
so let's make sure that we understand
every time you think of orbital
you have to think of balloon
okay that's what that's what an orbital
is
okay so here
uh you see the hydrogen
balloon
on the top okay
and you see that electron blue electron
bead
rolling around the red
center which is uh the nucleon in this
case is the proton there is no
um
there's no neutron in the
ordinary hydrogen right you got to go to
deuterium it's got one neutron tritium
has two neutrons but the standard
hydrogen has no neutrons so it's just a
proton and an electron bead going around
but as you can see the electron bead is
not tied
by any string or anything to the center
ball
and so the question is what is that blue
sphere within which the electron is
trapped
what they explain
what they always you know whenever they
have to use for example
uh the
hydrogen atom to explain something for
example like electricity even though you
can't do with hydrogen but just for the
sake of simplicity let's assume you do
electricity with hydrogen atom what's
moving according to them is one electron
from atom to atom
and you can understand that if the
electron bead is just rolling around the
nucleus
and nothing is tying it to the
hydra to the nucleus you can imagine
that electron b just going out for
whatever reason whatever pushed it out
or whatever pulled it out and going from
atom to atom but
the question is that's the atom that
they explain that's the one they use for
electricity that's the one they use for
um
ionization
but then when you ask um okay so what
does the uh atom really look like well
they say it looks more like a cloud
and what they draw is that
um
orbital that energy level the blue one
and it's nowhere to be found what is an
energy level
well it's a region within which you can
find the electron bead that's all it is
if it's a region it's a concept
i'm talking about is that a membrane are
we staring at a membrane
or some kind of sphere
that a solid that the electron for some
reason cannot escape
what is that blue thing
and you won't find an answer to that
question anywhere because they
immediately they talk about math they
start talking to you about abstractions
they say well uh you got to study math
in order to understand what that is
no no i need if you're going to draw it
if you're going to illustrate it you've
got to
name it and if you're going to say that
it's a concept called energy level or
orbital which is just a bunch of orbits
of an electron bead which means that
within that region you can find the
electron bead a region is not a physical
object you can't say a region
not my wall down
the word region cannot be used as a
physical object and that's what that is
just a region
that for some reason the electron cannot
escape
and then you know the electron doesn't
fall to the nucleus either so there's
something preventing the electron from
falling to the red ball
and so it's all screwed up
the whole picture is screwed up okay
but that's how the orbital is
conceptualized as some kind of sphere
that surrounds the proton and the
electron bead is
uh trapped within that sphere for some
reason something pulls that electron out
and now it can start flowing in the case
of you know higher level
elements like iron and so on and now you
have electricity your first ionization
electricity but
so so the electron beat has this
possibility of going into the conduction
band and start flowing and you say hold
it how did it escape
the
sphere this uh orbital
and again they say well it's the energy
you have to pull it out with energy
whatever energy is which is that's
another concept so we have concept on
top of a concept we have concepts
interacting with concepts that's all we
have okay
that's important because if you're going
to do physics hopefully you don't do it
with concepts you do it with physical
objects
okay okay so where did all this start
well we can take it back all the way to
mr democritus he's uh one of the
champions of the indivisible known also
as the atom
uh
something you can't cut
and he was a student apparently of
lucifus
and they were both uh they weren't
really athenians i put there the
parthenon but but they were
up north even beyond macedonia okay so
they were on the other side of what was
known as greece but they were part of
the same culture okay and yeah they came
up with this indivisible and uh they
were criticized by people in athens
later on
a couple hundred years later by people
like
plato and aristotle who analyzed uh
what's up what uh democritus said but
democrats said something more or less
correct which is
there is only atoms
and empty space
the rest is just pure nonsense okay more
or less that's what he said yeah
okay it turns out that we have to wait
many many years
uh 2 000 years almost for there to be an
improvement over uh democritus is
adam okay it was tackled at the
beginning of the 19th century
by mr dalton and
some people say he was he plagiarized
uh what others had already done but this
is about the best we have and what
dalton essentially
proposed in 1803 i think it was uh he
proposed that
there were different elements that
had different types of atoms and he
didn't know what they looked like but he
just drew them differently so that
people would recognize that these atoms
were all different okay
and so he built his first uh you could
say periodic table that's the the most
fundamental one that
we had the first one
and again this this was the first time
since the days of democritus that we had
notions of what an atom was and what
these people are saying that atoms are
different
is it's not that all atoms are alike
like democritus suggested they're all
little balls
uh dalton in his generation were saying
you know there are different
uh
uh
levels of um
of atoms they're they look different if
we had god's eyes you could see in there
and i think he drew him more or less the
same except that he put a little cross
here and whatever an x on another one
and so on so
he made cosmetic changes because he had
no idea he was just saying that they're
different because they had different
weights they had different reactions and
he noticed that in the lab he was a
chemist a chemist and so he noticed some
of these differences and eventually this
notion
uh you know surged from his generation
it wasn't only him okay but he wrote
about it and we won't see much of an
improvement again until we get to mr
thompson also
and for the atom and what he suggested
is the atom especially the hydrogen atom
right was some kind of uh what they call
the plum pudding model they had this uh
positive uh
uh ball sphere and they had all these
little negative beads um
somehow uh meshed in there okay they
were floating around in this uh cake
okay this was the first
notion of what a hydrogen atom could
look like possibly okay
and of course it didn't stop there a
couple years later in fact not too long
after that about 15 years after
uh rutherford and bohr you know they
came up with the planetary model look
more or less like this
okay and they were able to
i guess explain electricity in these
terms as well uh other people in that
age they figured out that the electron
was moving from atom to atom okay but
this was their atom their hydrogen atom
okay later on it was modified just
slightly so that the quarks in the
center we saw that the other day the
quarks in the center uh were
invented or put in there by hand like we
talked the other day so uh now we had
these quarks and they were kept together
again by some kind of membrane and by
the gluons that pulled them together and
those are the springs that are
helping these balls bounce uh back and
forth against each other but essentially
this was the atom a little bead
the planetary atom a little bead going
around the nucleus okay
solar system type atom
okay suffered a couple more um
modifications in the uh 1920s roaring
20s and here you have uh two people who
worked on that one was louis de broglie
he was a french guy
and the other fellow was max born okay
germanthal
and one guy said look uh we have these
integral waves
and the electron is really spread around
okay around the
nucleus borne came up with the cloud
model uh
he was on again these guys had other
people working at the same time these
are just the
highest honchos that worked on these
things the guys that were given the
credit for a lot of this stuff and what
born did he came up with cloud model he
said well the electron is really
distributed
all around
the uh
the nucleus
and so now
you have what is developing here is the
cloud model in other words the orbital
because what you're staring at there is
this orbital that's
coming into
is being born okay i guess that's why
his name was born it was being born
because uh originally you had the
planetary model de broglie says uh hold
it it's not really a circle it's a
integral wave
you cannot imagine why the electron beat
would go in and out to form that
integral wave
okay because if the electron is a b why
would it go back and forth maybe it's a
hula hoop that goes all around
and now born is saying the whole
nucleus is being encapsulated within
a cloud
a cloud of what well a cloud of
electrons what do you mean a cloud of
electrons well these electrons are
moving around they form like a cloud
oh yeah but the hydrogen atom has only
one electron
and so they had to come up with a notion
that the electron is everywhere at once
because it behaves like a wave and a
wave is everywhere etc etc etc so this
electron which is a little bead suddenly
covers the entire
atom like a membrane like a
like a ball like a sphere
solid sphere in fact because the
electron cannot fly out okay so
this is how these notions were developed
and uh
they did a lot of math a lot of
equations to show that that was the case
and the number one guy there was
schrodinger uh the guy who invented the
dead
live cat right
and so surely your equation that's an
important equation in quantum probably
the most important one
and what it does is it calculates the
evolution of the wave function over time
it requires three quantum numbers known
as
n l and m
and to specify a wave function for the
electron
and there you see it at the bottom how
the wave function is moving through time
right quantum numbers provide
information about the spatial
distribution of an electron
okay what are these people talking about
what is this equation what what does it
do for us
and what it does it's maps
these so-called orbitals these uh
energy levels it tells you what the this
looks like okay that's essentially what
these people are talking about they're
gonna map
the atoms okay
and so yeah you get to this point
where uh here's the quantum um
version of what these people are talking
about
uh and these are the quantum numbers the
that
are included in the uh
schrodinger equation you have the n l
and m the s is not part of it so but
it's the fourth quantum number there but
it was not included in the schrodinger
equation at the time but what is this
the n is the distance from the center of
the nucleus to the electron bead okay
it's that distance the azimuth or
latitude the electron bead has along the
orbital shell that's what the second dl
is and the m is the longitude okay so
you have latitude longitude and
essentially the distance from the center
that's what
the equation essentially does if you put
that in there it gives it maps out
the region in which an electron is
trapped or you could say the
the region that the electron uh
draws or illustrates
paints okay
under the rope model we use those same
numbers we have no problem with
schroedinger's equation except that what
we're talking about is not an electron
bead
that's going around we're talking about
a membrane just like we just saw with
all these pictures where they show a
membrane and that's exactly what the
rope model proposes that they are in
fact membranes what is the n it's the
radius of the electron shell
it's not the distance from the electron
bead to the center it's the radius of
the shell
the latitude is the location along the
shell and the longitude is a location
along the magnetic thread okay so we we
can use the same equation okay that
we're starting your head except that
with that same equation what we're
actually doing is mapping the sphere not
the orbital not an abstract orbital but
an actual membrane that encapsulates the
proton star
okay so
we have no problem with schrodinger's
equation i think it was a good effort
on the part of schrodinger you know one
of the first
persons you do want to take your hat off
for coming up with that equation because
it helps us map
the uh
the electron shell
and again it's uh they called it a cloud
they call it a shell
they treat it as a sphere and then they
deny all that so you know it's a little
bead and what you're talking about is a
region
and then they have all these regions
interact they get rid of a little bead
and they just have the
regions interacting
they have two concepts
you know interacting it's like a region
of space with another region of space
there's nothing there and the regions
interact
so again
they're dealing with abstractions okay
they're not dealing with physical
objects
okay and so here we have the rope model
of hydrogen gas h2
two hydrogen atoms and what has happened
is the
membranes have
fused okay that's what's happening and
again these things are spinning okay and
that's how they merge into each other
okay
ours looks like the true
h2
gas molecule here it is you can see that
the h molecule that they
paint is the one at the bottom two h
atoms that are merged in some kind of
figure eight
and they treat those
membranes
i mean those orbitals as membranes they
treat the energy levels as actual uh
you know things
and that's exactly what we're saying
we're saying that what they're actually
uh
representing there is two atoms that
have their membranes fused okay so
we're consistent with what uh what with
the orbital notion but the orbital is
not a region the orbital is actually a
membrane okay
in contrast
here we have the uh
quantum version
uh they showed the one on the left
but that's not the one that you see in
the standard model the one you see in
the standard model is the one on the
right you see a proton and you have an
electron bead
and that blue
circle those two blue circles what are
those well those are supposedly the
regions in which the electron bead can
be found
and of course that's the two-dimensional
version when you have the
three-dimensional version you have the
one on the left and that's they do that
you can see that they forget about the
electron bead now they're merging the
the membranes which are not membranes
according to them just regions for some
reason those regions
uh
emerge and form a bigger region
okay so again uh
it's lying that's what it's called
scientific lying okay they're lying
because
they're not showing what they're saying
what they say is the one on the right
and what they
uh show is what the one on the left and
you're asking what are these regions are
they physical entities because they're
merging obviously they're talking about
a membrane of some kind which is what
the rope model says
and that's not what they explain what
they explain is the one on the right
okay so
keep that in mind how how
what they say doesn't match what they
illustrate that's what i'm saying okay
okay so here are my conclusions okay
the quantum orbital uh essentially is
many orbits it's what they're saying is
that's where you can find the bead if
it's not orbiting we don't care what
they're saying is that's the region
where you can find the electron beam
they put all these together and they say
that's an orbital
and what is that really is it the
location where you can find the electron
bead they don't care about that either
what they're talking about is energy
levels they're saying at this energy it
goes from this energy level to this
other energy level within that those two
energy levels whatever that is we can
find this region and we're going to call
that region a uh an energy level or
an orbital okay and for some reason you
know the electron beat in case of the
hydrogen atom can't fall to the atom to
the nucleus that means there's some kind
of region some kind of barrier that
prevents the electron beam from going
south
also so you figure it out
so uh what is an orbital a region where
the electron beam can be found okay
uh region is treated as a rigid membrane
for binding atoms into molecules right
you have all these regions they emerge
they form molecules
and the h2 uh simulated with regions
okay not with orbiting bead model they
forget about the bead when they're when
they're
making these uh cell models these
region models these orbital models they
forget about the bead completely they
just deal with the orbital okay and you
say what are you talking about well i'm
talking about uh a region what is the
region well we don't know
e bead uh the electron b can't escape
the region for some reason you know
it's treated as a membrane again i mean
if it's a region why can't the beat
escape the region
and now they treat it as a membrane they
they insinuate to you through
illustration that you're dealing with a
membrane and somehow the electron beat
cannot escape that membrane that wall
so they turned a region into a wall
into a sphere
under the rope model the orbital is a
membrane
very simple and there is no bead so
there is no bead to escape okay and yeah
here's
here's the model that i put for the
orbital for the quantum model okay there
you see it
hey that's the orbital
uh
those are the different levels energy
levels and i guess the eggs cannot leave
their energy level for some reason
okay there you have the quantum orbital
in a nutshell
so yeah uh
all you can figure out here is that
there is a difference between what they
illustrate what they talk about they
explain something different they
describe something different they say
that we have an orbital or region
and somehow that region turns into a
membrane that explains why the electron
beat cannot escape
because it's not a region a concept
it's an actual membrane a wall that
stands in between the electron and
freedom
and then for some reason these electrons
are able to go in the conduction band
when they are ionized by some external
force
and what's the external force they say
it's energy whatever energy is somehow
pushes or pulls them out and that's when
they start flowing
that's in a nutshell the orbital for you
okay let's go to some of the
questions and comments people made
here's one file and he says
uh oh yeah this is the one that i
couldn't get to see the other day i
don't know why anyways now i see it
there it says to calculate the number of
atoms in a sample divide its mass
in grams
okay so first you gotta
figure out the mass
okay before you calculate the mass
because you gotta weigh it okay so first
of all mass is not the number of atoms
according to him right okay because he
says
mass in grams
so and he says to calculate the number
of atoms
in a sample
divided by its mass
and so that means that the number of
atoms
is not the mass according to him that's
out of his statement there okay
and then you gotta weigh it
you gotta weigh the mass
to find out how much it weighs and then
you do the calculation
okay so we have a dog chasing his tail
he's running around in circles okay
by the same atomic
mass
by the amu atomic mass from the
periodic uh table
then multiply the result by avogadro's
number yeah no matter what you do
then you have to state your your
result for mass
in quantity of atoms
or whatever you know
he says avogadro's number that's fine we
don't care but it's got to be a number
it's got to be a um
a
integer
it's got to be an energy
in other words you got to say
this this thing has one trillion atom uh
one trillion atoms or whatever one
trillion whatevers what one trillion
units
units of mass
that's how you have to specify mass you
can't say it weighs one kilogram because
then you're talking about weight
and if i have to and like he says there
again chasing his tail around he says
number of atoms okay that's the number
of atoms but the number of atoms is not
mass because to calculate mass
you need to weigh it
and it's in grams
then you have to perform a calculation
to give you number of
atoms
and and once you have the number of
atoms you don't specify mass and number
of atoms you specify it in terms of
grams so again it's just chasing this
tail around that's all they've done all
these years and yeah and then we have
another problem there which is secondary
problem which is you know if i wait on
the moon and i weigh it on mars
i'm going to have different results for
for the weight the the weight that i'm
going to be dividing by avogadro's
number or whatever okay and so
you know i'm going to get a different
mass for each one of these planets
because that's the weight of this ball
in different planets or different
celestial objects so if it weighs 100
kilograms here on earth and i weigh it
on the earth on the moon instead
i can't perform the same calculation
that i perform in mars
okay so again you know this uh method of
calculating mass
it's relying on weight and weight
changes from planet to planet
okay so
uh there's several problems with that
definition that notion of mass okay and
really the the best way to show here is
that you know uh
weight is in kilograms we stay waiting
kilograms always people say out there
well that's the one in ordinary speech
that's the common notion the ordinary
notion fine great what is it in
so-called science physics what what is
mass in physics and they say what's
quantity of matter okay then why did you
specify it in kilograms first problem if
it's quantity of matter give me a number
a trillion atoms
then that or a trillion units of mass or
whatever then then we would have mass
because that would match the definition
which is quantity of atoms now they
don't give you quantity of atoms they
give you a measurement which we identify
in ordinary speech with weight
great now this vowel says well you got
to take that weight and divide it by
make a calculation there and now you're
going to come up with number of atoms
great i come up with a trillion atoms
why did you say it's it's a the mass is
a trillion atoms that would be the same
here on the moon and in mars no matter
where it would be a million a trillion
atoms or units of mass or whatever you
would have a number that's not the way
they say it they say it has a mass of so
many kilograms
so yeah they're chasing their tail
around okay they never figured out the
difference between mass and weight and
there is no difference because the way
they determine mass is by weighing
and so there can be no difference uh if
i take uh
a kilogram of whatever from the earth to
the moon
well it no longer weighs one kilogram
right
and they say well the weight change but
not the mass
well how do you know the mass didn't
change if the way you determine mass is
through weight
and now we're going to weigh it on the
moon
and how are you going to calculate the
mass
and if i take you to mars you know all
bets are off so yeah they have a problem
they can't say that
the mass did not change because it did
change because we determined master
weight
that's why it did change
okay
okay uh phil says
says uh
the day science uh this is from nick
tesla poor fellow yeah here he has said
something very stupid and he said the
day science begins to study non-physical
phenomena
it will make more progress in one decade
than in all the previous centuries of
its existence
so he's saying that uh physics is about
abstractions which is uh the antonym of
physical physical and abstraction are
two different things are completely
opposites and he's saying that it's got
to be non-physical it's got to be
abstract in order for it to be physics
that's what nick was saying here
anyways uh this fall continues he
analyzes that he says in physics
physical quantities are all those
quantities which are physically present
okay so i put a 5 there i guess that's a
physical quantity
and there you have a non-physical
quantity why because it's a 0. it's
non-physical quantities are those
quantities which cannot be seen
and you say well bill but i can see the
zero i can see that there yeah but see
you're supposed you're supposed to
understand that the zero represents
nothing
so you're not supposed to see it that's
why it's a non-physical quantity so a
five is a physical quantity because you
have five apples
but the zero is a non-physical quantity
because it's got zero apples i guess
that's his reasoning
okay so that's kindergarten
physics were you now let's do some a
little more advanced
college physics
my god i'm poor people okay here it is
uh let's see this fella says bill thinks
reality is real
aha
and there you have mother nature okay
and uh
she created two kinds of humans i guess
i would say this is a number off the top
of my head ninety percent of people are
spiritualist they believe in all kinds
of nonsense and only 10 are really
materialists that believe or
or sense that the universe is material
uh democritus uh only atoms in empty
space
yeah that's essentially it okay
in between you have the ropes he
couldn't figure that out then but
essentially he was correct everything is
matter that exists
because that's the definition of the
word exist
uh an object that has location with
respect to other objects okay so then
exists you want god to exist no problem
god had better
be tied to the
you know to the network to the rope
model okay all atoms should be connected
he should be made out of atoms as a
minimum otherwise god doesn't exist by
definition
okay and yeah 90 of people are
spiritualists and they believe like this
guy that reality is real or that reality
is not real so let's correct them let's
show where he uh
misconstrued
what he said there
and here it is a real object uh what we
do by the way is we define these terms
so that we can talk intelligently okay
so we have to define what reality is and
what real means we have to define these
words if we're going to make a case for
them and real is an object with location
there you have a definition you don't
like the definition you have to put
another definition there to counteract
it but that's the definition that we're
gonna work with that one stays until
someone can knock it down and show that
there's something irrational about it
and they have a better one that they can
defend
okay
and then whatever is not a thing cannot
qualify to be real
according to that definition if it's not
an object
it cannot even fit the definition of
real
whether reality it's not a substance
reality is a concept there's no physical
standalone object called reality i can't
bring the reality and put it on the
table and say this is reality okay
so reality cannot be said to be real or
unreal okay
the word real requires an object reality
is not an object period we're done
objects can be said to be real if they
have location
uh if it's a concept it is for sure it
cannot have location and therefore it
makes no sense to say that reality is
real
okay
again a lot of this is because people
use words of ordinary speech they bring
them into science
physics right and they try to make a
case using ordinary speech they never
define these words because they think
that everybody knows what they mean
and it turns out that in the last 10 000
years no one defined the word real the
word exist synonyms right
and they never defined the word object
and so yeah that's where they lose the
word object destroys all religions
and once you define that word all
religions fall down because it's it's a
materialist
word word
okay you have to be a materialist to
understand the word object if you're a
religious fanatic or spiritualist you'll
never understand the word object because
it destroys your religion it's just that
simple
okay bill never defined what numbers are
one thought says yes i did in fact
i had a
couple of videos on that anyways the
number is to count that's what it's a
verb the word number is a verb
it's not a noun like it is in ordinary
speech or in mathematics now number is a
verb verb means that you're going to
move your hand up and down
and you're going to count
and you count one two three four five
you got a number five
five means you count it you move your
hand five times that's that's what
a number is
we're done
see how you seem simple it was number
the verb to count okay it's a verb
and people think it's a noun that's
they got that from ordinary speech also
okay and
final issue phil says
um physics is the science that studies
matter its fundamental constituents its
motion and behavior through space and
time and the related entities of energy
and force
uh yeah he copied this copied and pasted
and so he never analyzed it he doesn't
even know what he's saying he just
copied and pasted okay
that's the way people are they think
it's poetry they memorize these things
and they just recite it you know like
counting beads on an abacus
an abacus on a rosary
okay so uh what are the problems well
first the word study okay study does not
mean understanding as i showed at the
beginning of this lecture
uh i studied in orbital for a long time
i still don't know what it is
so you came to the wrong place today
okay i wasn't able to educate you
because i don't know what an orbital is
can't move through concepts the guy says
it's motion and behavior through space
and time space and time are concepts you
don't move through concepts you can move
through walls maybe you can move through
water maybe through air but you can't
move through nothing
okay
when you move through nothing
it's very scary okay try not to move
through nothing okay no such thing as
nothing
so you can't move through it
you can't cut nothing in half
okay energy uh is not an entity okay and
neither is force so again you can't move
through space time force and energy
okay and um
so we can't study uh things entities
known as energy and forces because
neither one are entities
entity is a physical object
an object okay uh it's a thing
and energy and force are not things
okay a force is a verb
and energy is a verb also it's an
undefined verb we still don't know what
energy is according to mr richard
feynman he says nobody knows what energy
is i agree with him
nobody knows what energy is i don't even
know what energy is okay so don't ask me
uh entity what is an entity a thing that
which has shape and physics rational
explanations of mechanisms not the study
of in physics we do not study in physics
we explain
with that i'll see you on